the biggest hack to stop caring about  other people's opinions to stop living  other people's version of your life and  to start actually feeling happy and  proud of yourself the biggest hack to  doing that is to figure out what you  stand for to figure out your single most  important core value i believe that  everybody has a single most important  core value and when you figure that out  it gives you a lot more clarity a lot  more direction a lot more confidence and  allows you to start to to do things that  you never thought were possible all of a  sudden that idea that you've got of oh  my gosh i could do this thing but then  never take an action on it things start  to happen for you because you have that  clarity of value